what are your particular words of advice
regarding the on the occasion of Ramadan
approaching us my advice would be that
every Muslim he or she should make it a
point that they should make a resolution
that they should fast each and every day
of this blessed month of Ramadan and we
should try and acquire all the benefits
of this month and we should not waste a
single minute in this blessed month on
things which are and try and concentrate
as much as possible in Remembering Allah
subhana wa tala we should try and look
for his Mercy we have to try and ask for
forgiveness we have to try and seek for
his love and we have to try and increase
our piety our righteousness and our
patience and our beloved Prophet mamm
sallah Ali wasallam said in
sari verm number three in the book of
fasting Hadith number one 903 our
beloved Prophet Muhammad sallallah Ali
wasallam said anyone who does not
leave the false action and false
speech Allah subhana wa ta'ala does not
care if he leaves his eating and
drinking that means if a person does not
abstain from false action and false
speech Allah subhana does not care if
you abstain from food and drink that
means you're fasting thing will not be
accepted unless you stay away from false
action and false speech and a beloved
prophet malli wasallam he also said it's
mentioned which is written in mus Ahmed
R number two page number 230 Hadith
number 7148 and it also appears
inai chapter number five Hadith number
where our beloved Prophet Mall Ali
wasallam said oh
people the Blessed month of Ramadan is
approaching and Allah has ordained for
you that you fast in this
month and the Gates of Heaven will be
open in this month and the Gates of Hell
will be closed and the Devils they will
be
Chained and this month is the
night which is better than a thousand
months and if a person is deprived of
the blessings in this month he's truly a
deprived person so we have to make it a
point that we gain the benefits of this
blessed
month a beloved Prophet malli wasallam
said it's mentioned s bukari Vol number
three in the book of fasting Hadith
number 1
1901 our beloved Prophet mm sallallah
Ali wasallam
said that anyone who fasts in this
month with faith seeking the reward of
Allah subhana tala all his past sins
will be
forgiven that means if you truly with
sincerity fast in this month and seek
the reward of Allah subhana wa tala all
our past sins will be forgiven imagine
it is such an easy way to have our sins
forgiven of the past and our beloved
Prophet M wasallam also said it's
mentioned
sari volume number three in the book of
fasting Hadith number 1904 this is a
very long Hadith which has basically
Four Points our beloved Prophet M Ali
wasallam said that all the children of
Adam all the Deeds that they do are for
themselves except for fasting fasting is
for me and I will reward
him and he further said that fasting is
a
shield it prevents you from
sin and the person who observes the fast
he should abstain from
obscenity from yelling and from
ignorance and if someone yells at him or
abuses him he should say I'm fasting I'm
fasting and the third point of beloved
Prophet said in this Hadith is that I
swear by Allah in whose hand is the soul
of Muhammad s wasallam that the breath
of a faster the person who fasts is
sweeter to Allah subhana wa ta'ala than
the scent of
musk and he finally said in this Hadith
that there are two things when a faster
is happy and looks forward to it the
first is when he breaks the Fast and the
second is when he meets the Lord Allah
subhana
tala and further it's mentioned in the
Quran in Sur chapter number 24 verse
number 31 it says or you believe
truly have faith in Allah subhana wa
ta'ala and seek the Bliss that means try
and enter Jenna it's mentioned Sur
chapter number
46 verse number 13 and
14 that those are the people who worship
none but Allah subhana wa ta'ala
and they are steadfast in faith the word
Isam they steadfast in faith that
there's only one Allah and no one else
and they shall not have any fear nor
that sh grief these are the people who
are the people of
paradise and they shall be rewarded for
all the goods they have
done so this is advice for the people
that they should take the best of this
month and should not spend time on
things and spend their time in the
worship of Allah and reming Allah
subhana wa tala and asking for
forgiveness
mallah